at this altitude I can run flat-out for
my hands this episode is brought to you
by ascent protein the cleanest least
processed protein I've ever consumed and
I have tried just about everything since
well before the 4-hour body I've started
my day with 20 to 30 grams of protein
first thing that has been part of my
routine but I don't always have the time
or necessarily the desire to cook an
entire meal so what to do protein
powders can be a fast way to get this
protein need met but most products are
full of crap
they're bleached they've excess sugar
terrible artificial sweeteners or just
straightforward low-grade low quality
protein a scent contains zero artificial
ingredients and the parent company is
actually cheese manufacturers so they
produce their own native proteins it's
it's really fascinating and I've looked
at their processing it takes or it took
them about five years to develop you can
mix the protein in as little as four
ounces without any clumps or issues of
mix ability whatsoever and they nailed
the taste they tested for instance
there's the chocolate version two
hundred and eighty two different
versions they put a lot of money in a
lot of time into R&D for this particular
product if you love coffee they also
have a brand new cappuccino flavor which
is a variation I've enjoyed if you
prefer to test something outside of the
traditional vanilla or chocolate and
they have both way and my seller casings
so if you want to say improve body
composition and recovery overnight slow
release you can take the micellar casein
or in my case whey protein I would take
post-workout for instance or in the
morning so check it out these guys are
really fascinating visit a scent protein
dot-com forward slash Tim that's a scen
TPR OT
i n calm a sense like first descent
going up ascent protein calm /t Tim and
you will receive 20% off your entire
purchase if you want a very quick xx 30
gram dose to start your day or after
workout this is a fantastic option it is
arguably the best that I've found so
again check it up a scent protein comm
forward slash Tim this episode is
brought to you by 4 Sigma deck
you might remember 4 sig Matic for their
mushroom coffee which was created by
those clever Finnish founders and when I
first mentioned that coffee on this
podcast the products sold out in less
than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades I have a
largely fixed that but still shutting
off my monkey brain has never been easy
still isn't easy very often and I found
reishi which have been fascinated by for
a few years now has been very very
effective and calming their old formula
however for sig Maddox old formula
included stevia and I like to avoid
sweeteners all sweeteners for a host of
reasons and I then just ping them and
asked hey guys
I would love to experiment with this and
maybe actually suggest it but I'd like a
version without sweeteners if you'd be
open to it if too much of headache don't
worry and they are always game for
experimentation so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
bag
you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily here's some recommended
copy that they put in the read so I'm
gonna read it and I'll give you my take
quote a warning for those in the
experimental mindset reishi is strong
and bitter in parentheses like any great
medicine so if the bitterness is too
much I recommend
trying it with honey end or nut milk
such as almond milk and quote so I'm
gonna say no you should suck it up and
you should drink the tea because it's
not that bitter and maybe she take the
advice of all Chinese people when
they're criticizing youngins when they
say boo and I'm sure to cool which means
you're not able to eat bitterness bitter
is in many cases an indication of things
that help liver detoxification and so on
not saying that's the case here but I've
tested this reishi lecture on family
members on friends everybody has liked
it it's a little bit earthy it's not
that hard so I would just say suck it up
and know don't put it in honey or a nut
milk or any of that [ __ ] just drink the
goddamn tea it's delicious I think right
if you like puer that kind of stuff that
type of tea you're gonna dig it so just
try it okay back to then my read if
you'd like to naturally improve your
sleep both on set and quality I think
naturally you might just enjoy this
ratio lecture without any sweeteners it
has organic reishi extract organic
fueled mint extract organic rosehips
extract organic Tulsi extract and that's
it no fancy stuff no artificial
whatchamacallit anything so check it out
go to four sigma tech comm forward slash
ferrous and get 20% off this special
batch I don't know if they're gonna be
making much more of this since it was
made specifically for you guys so do me
a favor and try it out so that they
continue to be open to experimenting
with me to create products for you guys
specifically check it out for sig Matic
that's fo you are SI GMA TI c-calm /e
ferrous f e RR ISS and get 20% off the
special batch and you must use the code
ferrous to receive your discount fer our
ISS so again go to 4 Sigma 2 comm
forward slash ferrous and then use code
ferrous for 20% off of this rare
exclusive limited run of reishi mushroom
elixir for nighttime routines without
any sweeteners enjoy
well hello there welcome to another
episode of the Tim Ferriss show where it
is my job to share the habits tools and
patterns of world-class performers of
all different types this special episode
is shorter than usual and features
thoughts and recommendations from Debbie
Millman who in her first appearance on
this podcast gave a wide-ranging and
very emotionally impactful interview
that is still one of the most downloaded
episodes of all time on this podcast you
can check that out at tim dot blog
forward slash debbie if you want a
longer form conversation but this will
be a shorter taste of debbie debbie at
Debbie Millman on Twitter has been
called quote one of the most influential
designers working today
and quote by graphic design USA she is
the founder and host of design matters
the world's first and longest-running
podcast about design where she's
interviewed nearly 300 design luminaries
and cultural commentators including
Massimo Vignelli and Milton Glaser
debbie has supposed to put it one way
done at all her work has been exhibited
around the world she is the president
emeritus of AIGA one of only five women
to hold the position in the
organization's 100-year history the
editorial and creative director of print
magazine and the author of six books in
2009 Debbie co-founded alongside Stephen
Heller the world's first master's
program in branding at the School of
Visual Arts in New York City which has
received international acclaim so she
has been on many different adventures in
many different fields and has learned a
lot of very very impactful lessons that
you can apply hopefully to your own life
in this episode debbie outlines more
than a few things but among them she
talks about how to bounce back from
rejection and criticism and share some
of her personal stories the importance
of mental health whether courage or
confidence is more important if you had
to pick one five questions to help you
clarify your own purpose and much much
more so without further ado please enjoy
this sure with Debbie Millman
Debbi what is the book or books that
you've given most as a gift and why or
what are one say two three books that
have greatly influenced your life well a
book that has influenced my life and one
that I keep going back to over and over
is the anthology the voice that is great
within us American poetry of the 20th
century gorgeously thoughtfully and
carefully edited by Hayden Carruth it
was required reading in a summary
college class I attended back in the
early 1980s this funny-looking book
introduced me to my most treasured
deeply felt poem Maximus to himself by
Charles Olson which has since become the
blueprint of my life as well as the
poetry of ginnis levert of Adrienne Rich
Ezra Pound Wallace Stevens and so many
more I still have my original copy from
the 1980s and though the cover has come
off and the spine is cracked in numerous
places
I will never replace it and Tim I
thought I'd read a version of Charles
Olsen's Maximus to himself since it is
my favorite poem and I get such great
joy reading this Maximus to himself by
Charles Olson I have had to learn the
simplest things last which made for
difficulties even at sea I was slow to
get the hand out or to cross a wet deck
the sea was not finally my trade but
even my trade at it I stood estranged
from that which was most familiar was
delayed and not content with the man's
argument that such postponement is now
the nature of obedience that we are all
late in a slow time that we grow up many
and the single is not easily known it
could be though the sharpness the
achiote I note in others makes more
sense than my own distances the
agilities they show daily who do the
world's businesses and who do nature's
as I have no sense I have
either I have made dialogues have
discussed ancient texts have thrown what
light I could offered what pleasures do
seat allows but the known this I have
had to be given a life love and from one
man the world tokens but sitting here I
look out as a wind and water man testing
and missing some proof I know the
quarters of the weather where it comes
from where it goes but the stem of me
this I took from their welcome or their
rejection of me and my arrogance was
neither diminished nor increased by the
communication it is undone business I
speak of this morning with the sea
stretching out from my feet what
purchase of a hundred dollars or less
has most positively impacted your life
in the last six months or in recent
memory well the purchase that has
influenced me over the last six months
is the Apple pencil I do so much of my
art work by hand and now there is a
device that draws and feels like a real
pencil that I can use electronically
it's changed the way I work
how has a failure or apparent failure
set you up for later success do you have
a quote favorite failure and quote of
yours Oh Tim I have so many failures I
think the first decade of my career were
experiments and failure rejection and
humiliation but I do have a favorite so
I will share that in early 2003 a good
friend sent me an email with the subject
line that read begin drinking heavily
before opening the email contained a
link to a blog titled speak up the first
ever online forum about graphic design
and branding in the world suddenly
sprawled before my eyes I found myself
reading an article that disparaged my
entire career this particular incident
in tandem with a number of historical
rejections and setbacks and humiliations
me into a really deep depression and I
seriously considered leaving the design
profession altogether however however in
the 14 years since this occurred this
utter takedown of everything I'd done to
date and everything I thought was a
complete and total failure for a long
long time
ultimately transformed into the
foundation of everything I've done since
everything I am doing now contains the
seeds of origin from that time so it
turns out for me the worst professional
experience I faced
ultimately became the most important
defining experience of my life
Debbie if you could have a giant
billboard anywhere with anything on it
what would it say and why this is easy
my billboard would save this busy is a
decision I say this all the time at
nauseam and here's why of the many many
excuses people used to rationalize why
they can't do something the excuse I am
too busy is not only the most
inauthentic it is also the laziest I
don't believe in too busy busy is a
decision we do the things we want to do
period if we say we're too busy I
believe it is shorthand for not
important enough
it means you would rather be doing
something else that you consider more
important that thing could be sleep it
could be sex it could be watching Game
of Thrones if we use busy as an excuse
for not doing something what we are
really really saying is that it's not a
priority it's not as important to us so
simply put you don't find the time to do
something you make the time to do things
I think we're now living in a society
that sees busy as a badge it has become
cultural cachet to use the excuse I am
too busy as a reason for not doing
anything we don't feel like doing the
problem is this if you let yourself off
the hook for not doing something for any
reason you won't ever do
if you want to do something you can't
let being busy stands in the way even if
you are busy make the time to do the
things you want to do and then follow
through and do them what is one of the
best or most worthwhile investments
you've ever made this answer might
surprise you or maybe not but the best
investment I've ever made was in
psychotherapy when I first started I was
in my early 30s and the bills
practically killed me but I knew I
needed to deeply understand all the
destructive things that had happened to
me in order to try to live a remarkable
life despite these things and I wanted
this more than anything over the years I
still sometimes smart at the moment at
the monthly invoices but I've never
doubted that this investment has
profoundly profoundly shaped who I've
become and although I still think I have
a lot of work to do it's changed and
then saved my life in every imaginable
way and I'm in what is called
psychoanalytic psychotherapy
put another way psychoanalysis with an
emphasis on self psychology and so for
me talk therapy is the only thing that
I've ever really felt drawn to things
like EMDR and behavior modification
might be really really helpful for other
people but they seem a little bit too
voodoo for me so some things that I
think are important to consider strictly
from my perspective I'm not an expert at
assessing or analyzing the value or
worth of psychoanalysis only I am able
to convey what this has done for me but
for me once a week therapy did not work
well twice and more gives you continuity
and an opportunity to germinate in a way
that once a week doesn't also once a
week almost feels like a catch-up you
sort of bring the therapist up to speed
on what happened in the last week and
then you have 20 minutes to sort of talk
about what's happening right now
therapy takes time I often say that
anything worthwhile takes a long time
and therapy is one of those things I've
been in therapy for a really long time
for decades but I can now after those
decades actually point to impaired
Oracle evidence of how my behavior in
the world by my sense of who I am has
fundamentally fundamentally changed and
so being in therapy and being a therapy
for any length of time it takes
dedication it takes stamina takes
resilience persistence and a lot of
courage to face things that you might be
really afraid to look at so it's not a
quick fix but but like I said it's
really saved my life try and tell your
therapist everything if you edit who you
are or if you pretend to be something
that you're not in order to impress the
therapist if you want to project who or
how you want to be seen it will take
that much longer so just be yourself
they've likely in their practice heard
everything they understand humanity so
just be yourself if you're afraid your
therapist will judge you tell them that
also because that whole projection is
really critical to understanding the
dynamic that you have with people in
general so all of these things are
really important to talk about there is
no shame in feeling shame and I'm saying
this from a place of deep empathy almost
everyone feels shame I think Bernie
Brown says that anybody that doesn't
feel shame is likely a pathological
person so almost everyone does in
therapy will help you understand it
there is nothing like understanding your
motivations and insecurities to help you
integrate all of those feelings in your
psyche in the most healthy and authentic
way so for me I would not recommend
going to a therapist that one of your
friends goes to asking your friends
forever and then going to somebody that
they see might seem like a good idea
because that person trusts them and
therefore by extension you might feel
like you can too but it ends up blurring
things quite a bit and I think most
therapists abide by this rule now of not
seeing friends of or clients of friends
things really do get very blurry and
Jews can get weird and I just don't
recommend that okay
big elephant in the room here it is
going to be expensive but what is more
valuable than better understanding who
you are breaking intrinsic bad habits
getting over much of your [ __ ] or at
least understanding why you do the [ __ ]
in the first place and generally living
a happier more contented more peaceful
life
one thing that I've come to understand
recently and this was actually not only
through the help of my therapist and
guidance from my therapist but also
through my dear dear friend Seth Godin
is understanding the difference between
happiness and pleasure and I think
people are often trying to reach for and
strive for pleasure and and the response
to trying to seek pleasure is actually
wanting more pleasure after that you
know we live on this hedonistic
treadmill we metabolize our purchases
and our experiences very quickly and so
when we have that pleasure or experience
that pleasure then we want more
happiness is very different happiness
essentially means you're okay as is you
don't need more you don't want more you
feel good with what you have and I think
that therapy really helps you understand
the difference between what you seek
what your motivations are and ultimately
what you want and how you can manifest
that in your life so breaking these
intrinsic bad habits getting over much
of your [ __ ] and generally living this
happier more contented more peaceful
life is something that I think is the
ultimate gift of therapy or the payoff
and and lastly my advice to anyone
looking for a therapist is to make sure
they're really trained I highly
recommend training here a PhD and MD
plus postdoctoral training you really do
get what you pay for here and I highly
recommend somebody that is truly fully
educated in what they do what is an
unusual habit or an absurd thing that
you love I've been told that because I
like to make up silly songs and then
sing them in all sorts of absurd
situations and occurrences that I am
trying to
my life into a Hollywood musical and and
since I was first told that I've come to
completely agree with that and I think
that is awesome
but I have songs for everything I have
songs I used to have songs for feeding
my cats but they've since both passed
away I have songs for my dogs
I have songs while I'm cooking I usually
take some well-known tune and then
rewrite the lyrics for whatever it is
I'm experiencing so for example when I
was feeding my cats when I would open up
the cans of cat food I would sing who
once said fancy who wants at feasts tea
who wants at fancy who wants at feasts
tea feasts tea fancy fancy feasts tea
let's open up the cans now they loved it
everybody else around me hated it but
they loved it in the last five years
what new belief behavior or habit has
most improved your life after a design
manners interview with the great writer
Danny Shapiro
we started to talk about the role of
confidence in success apparently I think
at that time about four new books on
confidence had come out and she went on
to state that she felt that confidence
was highly overrated and I was instantly
intrigued and asked her why and she
explained that she felt that most people
that she felt that most overly confident
people were really annoying and that
most confident people were usually a
little bit on the arrogant side she felt
that over exuding that amount of
confidence was a sure sign that a person
was compensating for some type of
internal psychological deficit instead
Danny declared that courage was more
important than confidence taking that
first step in doing anything was the
real key to begin to manifest the
possibility of that thing happening so
when you're operating out of courage
you're saying that no matter how you
feel about yourself or your
opportunities or the outcome you're
going to take a risk and take a step
toward what you want you're not waiting
for the confidence to mysteriously
arrive
and since then I've been thinking a lot
about well how do you develop confidence
how do you how do you bring that
confidence to whatever it is you do and
I've come to the conclusion that and
this is my definition of confidence now
is that confidence is the successful
repetition of any endeavor so if you
think back to something that you had to
learn for the first time walking for
example you didn't start walking and
just start walking perfectly you were
crawling you were holding on to things
and then ultimately you get that ability
to step up and take that first step and
then you learn how to walk but even a
better example I think is I think is
driving when most of us start driving we
have to take driving lessons we're
really nervous about being in the car
behind the wheel we have this big
instrument that we have to control most
of us really really nervous at our
driver driving test and are hoping and
praying that we'll be able to pass but
over time when she do pass once you have
your license you start driving more
regularly you turn on the ignition you
drive around you do your errands you
take road trips cross-country trips
whatever and after certain amount of
time when you get into the car and turn
on the ignition you don't worry about
the possibility that this might be the
day that you kill someone behind the
wheel you have what I call car
confidence you get in the car you know
how to drive and you figure that you're
going to be able to get from point A to
point B rather unremarkable and I think
that that is the case for anything that
we do anything new that we start it's
highly unlikely that we will feel
enormously confident doing something
we've never done before
it takes time to be able to manifest
confidence through the successful
repetition of any endeavor we end up
having a certain internal pattern
recognition by the fact that we've done
this thing before fairly well maybe
excellently and we anticipate that the
results will be the same the next time
we do it so the more you practice doing
something the better you will inevitably
get at it and your confidence will then
grow over time
what advice would you give to a smart
driven college student about to enter
the real world or what advice do you
think they should ignore well since I
teach I have a lot of opinions on what
advice to give college students I think
one of the most important is about job
hunting like everything else a
meaningful in life it takes training to
get good at job hunting you don't just
find and get a great job you just go to
the supermarket and pick a great job off
of a shelf you have to find and win a
great job begins to pool a very
competitive candidates who may want that
job as much if not more than you do
so finding and winning a great job is a
competitive sport that requires as much
career athleticism and perseverance as
making it to the Olympics you must be in
the finest career shape possible in
order to win there is very little luck
involved and I've done hundreds of
design matters interviews where I'm
sitting across people really successful
people that say oh it's just luck I just
got lucky and I look at them and I
always say really because it's very
little to do with luck there might be
some timing involved but it's the timing
that is resulting in showing up every
day doing the work getting better and
better and better at the work and then
being the person most qualified when
that opportunity shows up winning your
great job is about hard work
it's about stamina it's about grit
ingenuity and timing and what might look
like luck to you is simply hard work
paying off so here are some questions I
tell my students to ask themselves as
they set out on their path in the real
world to win a job am i spending enough
time on looking for finding and working
toward winning a great job am I
constantly refining and improving my
skills
what can I continue to get better and
more competitive at do I believe that I
am working harder than everyone else if
not what can and should I be doing in
order to be able to accomplish that what
are the people who are competing with me
doing that
I am not doing am i doing everything I
can every single day to stay in career
shape if not what else should I be doing
one piece of advice I think that people
should ignore is the value of being a
people person
because as lovely as it might be to be a
people person no one cares if you're a
people person have a point of view and
share it meaningfully thoughtfully
respectfully and with conviction
what are bad recommendations you hear in
your profession or area of expertise I
don't believe in work/life balance I
believe if you view your work as a
calling it is a labor of love rather
than laborious when your work is a
calling
you're not approaching the amount of
hours you are working with with a sense
of dread or counting the minutes until
the weekend
your calling can become a life-affirming
engagement that can provide its own
balance and spiritual nourishment and
ironically it takes hard work to achieve
this so when you're in your 20s and your
30s and you want to have a remarkable
fulfilling career you must work hard if
you don't work harder than everyone else
you will not get ahead also if you're
looking for work-life balance in your
20s or 30s you're likely in the wrong
career if you're doing something that
you love you don't want work/life
balance you want to be able to do this
thing that you love as often as possible
when you feel overwhelmed or unfocused
what do you do well as a loud-mouthed
native New Yorker I have often regretted
acting impulsively when I'm feeling
angry or frustrated and now when I feel
that familiar urge to respond
defensively or say things that I don't
really mean or bang out a wounded
response via email or text to some
suppose it hurt I wait I forced myself
to breathe take a step back and wait to
respond just an hour - or an overnight
retreat makes a world of difference and
if all else fails I try to obey this
message I got enough
fortune cookie which I have since taped
to my laptop
avoid compulsively making things worse
hey guys this is Tim again just a few
more things before you take off number
one this is five bullet Friday do you
want to get a short email for me would
you enjoy getting a short email for me
every Friday and that provides a little
morsel of fun before the weekend and
five bullet Friday is a very short email
where I share the coolest things I've
found or that I've been pondering over
the week that could include favorite new
albums that I've discovered it could
include gizmos and gadgets and all sorts
of weird [ __ ] that I've somehow dug up
in the the world of the esoteric as I do
it could include favorite articles that
I have read and that I've shared with my
close friends for instance and it's very
short it's just a little tiny bite of
goodness before you head off for the
weekend so if you want to receive that
check it out just go to 4-hour workweek
dot-com that's 4-hour workweek com all
spelled out and just drop in if your
email and you'll get the very next one
and if you sign up I hope you enjoy it
this episode is brought to you by 4
Sigma deck
you might remember for sig Matic for
their mushroom coffee which was created
by those clever Finnish founders and
when I first mentioned that coffee on
this podcast the products sold out in
less than a week it lights you up like a
Christmas tree which can be really
useful however recently I've been
testing the opposite side of the
spectrum a new product and that is their
reishi mushroom elixir to help me end my
day to get to sleep as you guys may know
longtime listeners at least I struggled
with insomnia for decades I've a largely
fixed that but still shutting off my
monkey brain has never been easy it
still isn't easy very often and I found
reishi which have been fascinated by for
a few years now has been very very
effective and calming their old formula
however for sig Maddox old formula
included stevia and I like to avoid
sweeteners all sweeteners for a host of
reason
and I then just ping them and asked hey
guys
I would love to experiment with this and
maybe actually suggest it but I'd like a
version without sweeteners if you'd be
open to it too much of headache don't
worry and they are always game for
experimentation so they created a
special custom version without the
stevia without sweeteners now it is part
of my nightly routine their ratio elixir
comes in single serving packets which
are perfect for travel and in fact I'm
about to leave the country right now and
I have a packet in front of me that's
just gonna sit in the end of my carry-on
bag
you only need hot water and it mixes
very very easily here are some
recommended copy that they put in the
read so I'm gonna read it and I'll give
you my take quote a warning for those in
the experimental mindset reishi is
strong and bitter in parentheses like
any great medicine so if the bitterness
is too much I recommend trying it with
honey and or nut milk such as almond
milk and quote so I'm gonna say no you
should suck it up and you should drink
the tea because it's not that bitter and
maybe you should take the advice of all
Chinese people when they're criticizing
youngins when they say boo and I'm sure
cool
which means you're not able to eat
bitterness bitter is in many cases an
indication of things that help liver
detoxification and so on not saying
that's the case here but I've tested
this ratio later on family members on
friends everybody has liked it it's a
little bit earthy it's not that hard so
I would just say suck it up and know
don't put it in honey or nut milk or any
of that [ __ ] just drink the goddamn tea
it's delicious I think if you like puer
that kind of stuff that type of tea
you're gonna dig it so just try it okay
back to then my read if you'd like to
naturally improve your sleep both on set
and quality I think naturally you might
just enjoy this ratio lecture without
any sweeteners it has organic reishi
extract organic field mint extract
organic rosehips extract organic Tulsi
extract
and that's it no fancy stuff no
artificial whatchamacallit anything so
check it out go to four sigma tech comm
port slash ferrous and get 20% off this
special batch I don't know they're gonna
be making much more of this since it was
made specifically for you guys to do me
a favor and try it out so that they
continue to be open to experimenting
with me to create products for you guys
specifically check it out for Sikkim
attic that's fo you are SI GMA t IC comm
forward slash ferrous fe are our ISS you
get 20% off the special batch and you
must use the code at Ferris to receive a
discount fer our ISS so again go to four
sig Matic compos lash ferrous and then
use code a ferrous for 20% off of this
rare exclusive limited run of reishi
mushroom elixir for nighttime routines
without any sweeteners enjoy this
episode is brought to you by ascent
protein the cleanest least processed
protein I've ever consumed and I have
tried just about everything since well
before the 4-hour body I've started my
day with 20 to 30 grams of protein first
thing that has been part of my routine
but I don't always have the time or
necessarily the desire to cook an entire
meal so what to do protein powders can
be a fast way to get this protein need
met but most products are full of crap
they're bleached they've excess sugar
terrible artificial sweeteners or just
straightforward low-grade low quality
protein a scent contains zero artificial
ingredients and the parent company is
actually cheese manufacturers so they
produce their own native proteins it's
it's really fascinating and I've looked
at their processing it takes or it took
them about five years to develop you can
mix the protein as little as four ounces
without any clumps or issues of mix
ability whatsoever and they nailed the
taste they tested it for instance the
chocolate version two hundred and eighty
two different versions have put a lot of
money and
lot of time into R&D for this particular
product if you love coffee they also
have a brand new cappuccino flavor which
is a variation i've enjoyed if you
prefer to test something outside of the
traditional vanilla or chocolate and
they have both way and micellar casein
so if you want to say improve body
composition and recovery overnight slow
release you can take the micellar casein
or in my case whey protein I would take
post-workout for instance for in the
morning so check it out these guys are
really fascinating visit ascent protein
dot-com forward slash Tim that's ASC ENT
PR OT ein comm ascent like first ascent
going up the scent protein comm forward
slash Tim and you will receive 20% off
your entire purchase if you want a very
quick xx 30 gram dose to start your day
or after workout this is a fantastic
option it is arguably the best that I've
found so again check it out
ascent protein comm forward slash Tim
you
you